and Luke cunan as the cross crease pass
goes off the boards and cunan will play
it ahead for carpenter carpenter gives it to
Smith and he'll launch one as erson bats it
away sometimes that's not a good thing
to have that third day off because they
had to sit on a 10 two loss here to the
Pittsburgh Penguins Kevin leank the pass
and they score and anony duclair and the
sharks are on the board just a minute 43
in nice pass there to leank I love the
fact that leank knew where declair was
takes one more step puts it over
to declair and declair knows he has
to get this Puck up the goenda the
bottom part you can see there's the
goenda beautiful shot really set up by Tai
Emerson on the Breakout that one point coming
in a shootout loss to the Colorado Avalanche
Flyers trying to get something going down in
the Shark Zone Kates muscled off the puck and
then losing it as he tried to deep his way out
of trouble was Carpenter a save there by Blackwood
hack out of the air nice little strike of a pass
on the breakout Blackwood he's seen plenty of this
team in his past of course all of his career in
the Eastern Conference Atkinson testing McKenzie
Blackwood who came up with the save there Buck
rims around to this side Tyson Forester again with
it the bump back by fary now Forester through his
screen in Blackwood with the glove save well
defended by Burrows on faraby now a chance
for Philadelphia comes to the feet of Blackwood
it's going to take that kind of an effort for the
Sharks to get out of this slump and so far we've
seen it through not quite the first half of this
first period Forester a shot and a big patch save
for Mackenzie Blackwood and certain players they
have been challenged by their coach they've been
challenged by their GM you would think certainly
by one another as Blackwood makes another save
and another cover up that time on the shot by
belpedio just kind of threw it in front of them
too far their Emerson looking to one time that
and just didn't execute the pass by granin now
Joel faraby five goals nine points on the year
for farab as Blackwood bottled it a bit they went
through some changes that you talked about in the
pregame show a new general manager Danny Brier
a new president of hockey operations Keith Jones
erson part of a California sweep for the pliers
last year they won all three games against the
team from this state and it was arson in goal for
all three including a victory here against the
Sharks Ruda that doesn't lead the Zone RI back
toward the networ it's block now Couer back to
the line a onetime Sav by black would fat rebound
shadowed by emberson now a change underway for
Philadelphia's Barby skated onto the ice they've
got numbers down low a pass into Baran he couldn't
handle it off his skate granin back to duclair
hurdle down low declair shoots that one's blocked
and knocked out in front of the net by sanheim
doesn't clear hurdle in alone and it's sto by
Arison duclair with the one timer didn't get all
of it they fight for it in front dived on by a
Philadelphia forward and finally Aron able to
get his glove over it it kind of gets a broken
play here as he's kind of lagging being behind and
it comes popping out to him looking for somebody
right there in the slot that's duclair popped
out perfectly and just couldn't get all of it
rolled over the top of his stick finally gets
a hold of it again nice job there by hurdle to
get it in there to Zin TR of pivot away down in
the corner from Nick seeler who's on top of him
Flyers clear it and come ahead short-handed we
mentioned they've got four shorties this year
Couer and a save by by Blackwood here's a break
now for the Flyers it's farby Joel farby and a
good back check there by Ruda and farby couldn't
get a quality shot away need help from hurdle here
to get it out kept in at the line now Couer as the
Flyers go to work Cam Atkinson back for Shan Couer
he'll go rink wine sanheim shot pinballs around
in front of Blackwood of a three-game California
road trip they will take them on to Anaheim and
LA and they'll actually go home before playing
the final game of their road trip officially at
Carolina Mike Hoffman that takes a bad bounce for
Philadelphia the Sharks unable to take advantage
now Hoffman sliding it down the board Zaden a nice
GI leank to burrow shoots and it's bought off by
Aron Zaden into the flyer Zone the gender Aron
gave it away a cutuk and Hopman tonight by Aron
as a coach you fann on that look at the empty
net TI by Kates now declair the
one-time they score William eckan a
power play goal two [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
nothing sharks get control of this working
on the top of the umbrella not going to mess
around hurdle park in front and gender moving
from his right to left Aron finds a little
bit of room there to the left and the shot
by eckan finds the back of the net through
that little little room right between the legs
of [Applause] Aron Ferraro after he failed to
handle it initially jams it ahead cunan sent
it in lton brings it right back in for Philly
lot far sight sanheim and a save by Blackwood
what a stopped by McKenzie Blackwood off Joel
Bary turnover by the sharks they don't get
it deep and this pass right here and look
at Blackwood not quitting on it moves over and
makes a beautiful glove stop on farab sanheim
with the pass and unbelievable stop [Applause]
there 24 saves for Blackwood as we get another
look at it the gather it in there may be
an issue here if the puck did bounce over
the goal line after it dropped to the ice and
they're looking for that now it was confirmed
that the puck did completely cross the goal
line we have a goal oh it's a goal so there
is another angle which we will bring you when
we get it that shows that that butross the goal
line connecting old stranger to that that's
connected from the Philadelphia Flyers chirping
From the Bench York into the middle Blackwood
fights for it he made the save now duclair
can't clear it it creates an offensive zone time
here Theo coach you looed up for a shot and he
lost the puck deloria gets it now a break here for
Philadelphia and the save made by Blackwood a nice
shot there from okuk and then the breakway halfway
and wow Blackwood with another great stop here
tonight halfway again comes off the boards
back for sanheim and over w ER right to the
net Blackwood the save tried to pull it in but
it stays alive to the Flyers into the middle and
chopping at it with sealer it comes back out as
the Flyers are changing on the Fly here Tipp it
for sealer he'll place it at an area in front of
the net for tippet taking whistles when he can get
him and Seer just trying to throw something in
here a floater and right there wow what a play
by hurdle the turnover in the filling Zone toas
hurdle circling the net tried to jab it home and
a chance for Smith in front and that one stopped
by arson now we keep an eye on Samuel Aron the
Philadelphia goenda will certainly try to get
out here soon but now declair comes in alone and
hits the post there's the turnover granin just
throwing it back in farby York trying to get
to the bench and duclair pulls it to the forehand
waiting out the golender and just run out of real
estate hits it off the side of the cage 15 to go
sanheim loads up Atkinson backs away from declair
back for sanan kkny in for farby that one won't go
final seconds here Blackwood with the [Music] save
there's the draw it'll go harmlessly to
the side of the net and that'll do it